wanda maximoff will be the villain
of doctor strange and dr strange the
multiverse of madness and she's gonna do
it
because her love vision is not the good
guy she thought he's also a villain
avengers versus their own teammate
hulk who is out of control so worst case
scenario a villain is turned by janet
van dyne or should i say
janet von doom
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars guys
there has been
a secret villain hiding in plain sight
in the mcu
this whole time and i'm not talking
about uncomfortable costumes that are
just a bit too tight but really
we like them that way this is rogue
theory the podcast that brings you the
wildest
nerdy hot takes on the topics that you
cannot stop arguing about
i'm marina mastros and with me today to
pitch the rogueist of theories
our new rockstar's own eric boss hello
everyone
how are you eric oh i'm doing good i'm
ready to go wrong
how's the dungeon uh just as musky
and toxic as normal perfect we're giving
you a little oxygen today
thank you uh
and also with this is america's uncle
tommy bechtel
hello yes my parents
my parents say i'm a late starter but
that's okay plenty of time to catch up
for the first time ever guys one of my
dearest closest
funniest friends the rest of you guys
is my good friend and very highly
qualified nerd hector navarro
thank you guys so much uh marina it's so
great to be able to um
try and make you laugh which i guess has
just been our relationship for over 10
years just me always constantly trying
to make you laugh so here we go
let's see if i still got it last time we
were on a computer you were hosting and
i was a guest and it's that's true
thank you for having me well hector it's
so great to have you on new rockstars
finally we've been such a big fan of
your work for a while and i don't know
what's taking so long but you're here
now and we're so happy
making it happen only had to be a global
pandemic for it to work out
awesome here we go first thing the major
thing we're talking about today
is the who is the secret mcu villain so
the mcu currently has a villain vacuum
all right there's a big
cartoon portable hole on the wall
that's there's something missing right
so among the many theories and rumors
is some speculation that a character
that we already know as a hero
or like a neutral supportive character
will get revealed to be secretly
evil the whole time okay so i'm not
talking about guys like bordeaux we
already know that he's gonna turn on
doctor strange we saw that in the um
end credit scene and secretary ross is
already kind of a villain so he doesn't
count
taskmaster will be unmasked as one of
the good guys of black widow
so none of that that's all disqualified
okay
so i want you guys to go super rogue
here which
non-villain mcu character has been
lurking in the shadows as a villain
this whole time eric so let's
rewind the clock a year my friends what
happened about a year ago
a much happier time where it seemed like
there was a bit of a future to the
cinematic universe rather than one
that's endlessly delayed well
there was a uh a glorious panel at
comic-con
in which we saw uh a whole bunch of the
mcu phase four titles that were coming
up in the pipeline
and then he brought out scott derrickson
to do the uh
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness panel and there was like a
surprise entry where he brought out
elizabeth olsen once more who was there
earlier for wandavision
who said that her show one division is
going to tie directly
into doctor strange two in the
multiverse of madness
what if what we were really seeing there
my friends was the
villain of the doctor strange sequel i
think
one division will establish wanda
maximov
will be the villain of doctor strange
and dr strange the multiverse of madness
and she's gonna do it
because her love vision is not the good
guy she thought he's also a villain
so oh how is this gonna work out i i'm
definitely not the first person to
speculate that uh juana maximoff might
turn
crazy and evil right a lot of people
have been saying that but here's how he
thinks specifically how it will happen
so is it because you've always hated
vision well yes that's true i mean
eric what every one of my theories oh
welcome to new rock stars hector every
episode i work at some hate on vision i
just think he's boring
and all of my theories in a way are just
trying to like reveal a deeper more
interesting layer to the character that
i hope is there
uh but so here's here's my theory for
this i think uh in one division we're
gonna see her trying to like resurrect
her old love she's gonna try to like
flip through different realities where
she has like a stable
happy family home and she's going
through different sitcom realities
because you know growing up as a kid
of television as we all were we
associated good family values with
things like full house
and roseanne in in
i love lucy whatever it is uh so
uh i think that's what she's trying to
do it's chaotic it's nuts we're gonna
get some hints toward um
like mephisto and agatha and we're gonna
go into some dark stuff but she's gonna
find out something about vision that's
really going to set her off
and we're gonna rewind to the events of
age of ultron in which there was a final
showdown between vision
and ultron and what was vision
originally conceived to be
but a future host body for the ultron
os right in that moment where he zapped
ultron
some of ultron got imprinted on vision
and buried deep down
inside of his source code so that the
the character that wanda loved all this
time
had uh had a bit of trace of ultron's
dna
ultron's digital personality ultron
is the root of visions personality
and he's just been masquerading this
whole time as this kind of like
altruistic figure
vision is the child's successor that
that ultron conceived his vision was
successful
that's what vision really means
and then uh wanda is going to figure
this out in the chorus of wanda vision
is just going to enrage her it's going
to set her off this character who i
thought i ripped his heart out in age of
ultron
i've been holding his heart in my hand
in a figurative way ever since
and she's going to lose it she's going
to get so enraged and she's going to say
this multiverse and it's all going to go
into a tailspin of madness
and it's going to be on doctor strange
to try to get a handle
on it and doctor strange the multiverse
of madness and and
fight against someone who should be a
fellow avenger but have to conquer her
in a way
that doesn't destroy her but preserves
the multiverse in a stable way that
hopefully will have um you know deadpool
and the other mutants in it
hey i'll i like that there's a comic
book precedent to that so i have no
choice but to stand
please don't okay please elaborate it
out it bums me out i mean it it's
there's been multiple stories where what
eric's describing comes to fruition
right what's the worst case
nightmare scenario for vision like he
opens his mouth and a big
old tron ball pops out and ultron's like
i've been here the whole time and it's
just like
it's such a bummer and and i do think
that
there's a strong possibility that and i
don't want to say
villain i don't want to say villain but
i think that
wanda maximoff is going to end up being
a major
threat in the mcu and i feel like in
retrospect when you read comic books
with scarlet witch
going crazy and losing her grip on
reality some of it can seem
a little bit tone-deaf some of it can
seem like oh it's a real bummer that you
took a very powerful female character
right
and reduced her to like she's crazy
she's hysterical but i think that
there's really interesting stuff that
can be done with the character and her
power level
and her grip on reality that will still
let her be a threat
but then still let her come out a hero
yeah so
yeah i agree and i think the best
villains are ones that are threats more
than just like
evil demons you know ones that like can
be contained and defeated in other ways
that aren't just like i'm going to
explode you now yes and it's more
dynamic because you can't just
like you said you can't just explode
them you you can't kill her like you
still have to somehow contain her
it's a it's more dramatic and more of a
conflict than just like
let's explode her although exploda's
verb is just like let's explode it let's
explode it
and hey who's better at doing that than
doctor strange he's like the one
hero we've seen in these movies who
didn't just like kill his person he
figured out a creative way to like trap
in a time loop and
and bring him to heal that way so like
this guy knows how to heal in other ways
he's
the ultimate physician he's a doctor
yeah he did this
lots of things um eric that's a great
theory
and um so for your rogies guys i have
these little fun decorative stones
they're nice and pretty oh great so what
they're dropping everywhere um eric your
color of
decorative stones is green okay okay and
you get two of them for that very solid
theory so here you go
what do they turn into oh my two
favorite uh little dudes mr masiks and
dancing groot
and he yay
i realize when i sway with him you can't
tell that he's dancing
hector why don't you crush eric with
your much better theory
i don't know about that but i do think
vision is a cool character okay let me
give it a shot
i believe that a current
mcu hero that could turn into a villain
slash threat villain slash
threat is a character who i think
is not at the end of his evolution
but somewhere in the middle and i think
people need to
think about where else this character
can go and i'm talking about
one who's been with us since almost the
beginning 2008 played by a different
actor
and now he is the wonderful mark ruffalo
i'm talking about hulk
okay so again let's go to the end of the
last
avengers movie avengers end game where
hulk because he was made
with gamma he had it in his blood was
the only one strong enough to be able to
snap everybody back into existence he
saved the universe but dude fried his
arm
and even in the final battle when he was
fighting with everybody he still had a
fried arm
and at the end when he was helping with
the time machine to send chris evans
back in time he had a fried arm and it
was in a sling the dude is hurt and
normally the hulk
has the greatest even better than
wolverine healing factor where the hulk
can just bounce back so
my theory is this at some point in the
future and i also want to give a shout
out to my buddy mr augustine rios who
originally pitched this to me
where he was like i think it's going to
be hulk and i went oh my god you're
right
oh my god you're right and here's why
what happens what happens at the end of
avengers end game he he hurts himself
right
banner is a scientist who's constantly
working on himself tweaking himself
we've seen sort of different evolutions
of hulk up to this point and the smart
hulk the professor hulk was sort of
where he became
enamored with the idea of like embracing
the hulk well now in an effort to try to
heal himself
and while still tweaking on the sort of
hulk formula that's that is
himself now he is going to unleash a
savage hulk he is going to go
too far the other end and create a
threat for the marvel universe
where we may get pieces of the storyline
world war hulk
where we're going to get this is the
reason why the remaining avengers i'm
talking captain marvel black panther
ant-man wasp spider-man doctor strange
whoever's left
yeah is going to need to sort of team up
again and this is an avengers level
threat
the villains who crop up in each
individual movie they're
always going to be compelling they're
always going to be interesting but the
great thing about
these big comic book crossover movies is
that when you
get to a concept that's as juicy as like
iron man versus captain america
you can't top it avengers versus their
own
teammate hulk who is out of control it's
a worst case scenario the thing that
he's always feared is he really loses it
and by that point hopefully we can even
get
uh uh hopefully we'll see some of the
she-hulk tv show that they're going to
put on disney parks
to sort of expand the hulk family if you
will we may get other supporting
characters we may bring back
liv tyler as betty we may bring back you
know
i definitely want to bring back general
ross and maybe he'll turn into
a red hulk or something to sort of
combat the the the main
bruce banner hulk that we know but at
the end of the day
his threat is going to become too
powerful and too dangerous for the world
and he will even
maybe even ask his avengers allies to
come and like take him out
and that's going to be a compelling
story that could be a story that i think
would be worthy enough
for like a final mark ruffalo film i'm
not saying he's got to die
but it's almost like a retirement movie
storyline for him you know the same way
chris evans got one robert downey jr
i say you can give one to ruffalo if he
can't have his own movie do it in an
avengers movie
to really focus the time on hulk i mean
scarlett johansson got her own black
widow movie even though her character
died and like
you know hawkeye is getting his own tv
show where's the love for the hulk
give us that love in an avengers movie
and make it heartbreaking to where like
we don't want to see the hulk
doing this and he doesn't want to be
doing it either but you know what and
you know what we might even
be able to get like a little evolution
of like he goes grey hulk he goes you
know
like uh uh different versions of the
hulk that we see kind of rapid fire in
one movie
and uh and it could end with the
avengers having to take him out
or save the day and he'll still live at
the end and
you could be secretly like back to a
hitchhiker
you think he dies the world thinks that
bruce banner's dead but he secretly
lived because he's a hero
it sounded like you were doing the
jurassic park theme song
it is universal yeah so that's how
universal is gonna take over the hulk
franchise and send them to jurassic
world
and it will become indominus rex versus
hulk
that's great yes that's great and
also it kind of addresses it or like
satisfies one of the complaints about
endgame which is like the hulk became
kind of weak or not weak but like lesser
less of a threat like he was too in
control and so people were like where
did he go where did he go
and so if your theory is correct and he
comes back and we see him at full
strength again
where he is the most dangerous thing out
there yeah i would love to see
a storyline where he gets so powerful
and so scary
that all the fanboys that we're
complaining about in game they go no i
want smart hulk back this is
scary he does kapooki he's too strong
because the hulk was to me a hero in
avengers end game but i totally
understand that the criticism of people
being like i wanted to see him hulk out
yeah i don't see him hulk
you know thanos beat him up he didn't
get to beat up thanos and i'm thinking
well the victory was
he brought back half of all life
guys
but listen marvel studios they're going
to have their cake in 82 they will
deliver
a big powerful strong out of control
hulk it should be a good story
and it could be mark ruffalo's last
major hulk appearance and then
then we're ready for she-hulk then we're
ready for amadeus cho then we're ready
for red hulk yeah
bring the rest of them on nice great um
hector
you get uh your decorative stones are
red
and you get three of them buddy oh my
gosh
wow what are they tuning into the
candles behind you whoa
they turn into these candles
wow that's so cool
i didn't i didn't have these behind me
but now i have three decorative stone
candles thanks marina
i'm going to put them right back where
they were
don't worry i'm keeping track of the
score you don't have to cool thanks
the pier one employee's gonna be real
mad if you move those candles around
yeah they need me out of here by six so
yeah that is not hector's house he's not
supposed to be there
well it's same for tommy yeah yeah uh
tommy
tommy what what do you have to what do
you think
oh what do i think well uh i have
uh i have a real whopper of a theory
here
uh not to build it up too much but this
one's really gonna blow your minds guys
because the uh my person goes from hero
to villain in a really shocking way
because we met her first as catwoman
years ago in the film batman forever but
i've got
michelle pfeiffer's janet van dyne
pulling the hill turn to the marvel
cinematic universe
so let's look out and remember where we
what
our involvement with janet van dyke to
this point uh which has been strictly
professional much to my chagrin
in the mcu janet van dyne was uh she was
lost in the quantum realm for 30 years
that's
yeah a long time i mean that's more than
i've been alive for
link uh it's theorized that uh at some
point she must have found her way to one
of the uh
the uh cities in the quantum realm what
we don't know is what she did
while she was there and we don't know
who she met
so i think a big reveal in the movie
ant-man 3 is going to be
a villainous turn by janet van dyne or
should i say
janet von doom keep the monogram
you do not have to change the initials
the towels remain
the bathrobe remains the bowling ball
remains because j
v d is still in business jean-claude van
damme could also steal all of her
monogrammed goods
and it would still be in play so here's
how i think that it's going to happen
while she was in the quantum realm she
was taken prisoner by
a uh by dr doom who has either been
banished there or is traveling there
because he likes to because he's dr doom
he's omega he can do whatever he wants
he can
frolic in the quantum realm he can
frolic in syracuse new york for all i
care he's dr doom
so he's going to take her prisoner
and there he's going to use one of two
things either his mind transference
power
or his mind control power to get her to
do his bidding what does he need
janet van dyne to do i think it's no
accident that scott lang found janet van
dyke i think dr doom
needed scott lang to find janet van dyne
so that she can steal pym particles
for him so i believe uh janet will
not necessarily be a true villain and
that their heart is bonus but under mind
control
we'll be doing the bidding of one dr
doom the defense rests their case
once again doctor doom taking over
people with mind control there's comic
book precedent so i have no choice but
to stand even though i don't
like any of these plans because it means
our heroes will be taken over
but if it's in a comic book i have no
choice but to love it
unconditionally some fun
like um proven evidence for tommy's
parallel there like when we first saw
janet van dy and she was wearing that
hood her face was covered
and a lot of people first like [ __ ] is
this doctor doom and it's
so similar that we used a thumbnail for
a recent video where we kind of made it
look like dr doom was coming through a
portal
for the hood silhouette we used janet
van dyne from ant-man
and just put two green eyes in there and
people like oh that looks like doctor
doom
we fooled ya we got you at the least
it's a visual homage to doom right
at least um tommy yes
that was excellent and your color of
decorative stones uh this is the only
the only time there's going to be
decorative stones used as rogies is when
i'm posting because they just like have
decorative like fun things around
and you boys will never have that except
for hector's candles uh
to unki tommy you get two blue you're
cold
all right decorative rogies what do they
turn into
oh it uh this is perfect this turns into
a copy of mae vinci's circle of friends
another uh a copy of frederick
bachmann's my grandmother asked me to
tell you she's sorry
uh retails for
16 from simon and sherwood
and it's firmly in league with roald
dahl
and neil gaiman a touching sometimes
funny
often wise betrayal of grief that's
my grandmother asked me to tell you
she's sorry on sale at bookstores now
that's great because the retail price
for one of these stones is also 16
so that's a one to one whoa perfect
trade perfect
one-to-one ratio right there guys before
we uh
move on to round two uh ankitami is
gonna help us thank our sponsors for
today
i would love to thank our sponsors all
of which are as close to me
as my own children let's start with my
first thanks
thanks to our friends at manscape for
sponsoring this episode
and thanks for our friends at manscape
for getting me through many what i would
call
troublesome grooming sessions manscape
offers precision engineering tools
for your family jewels and again you
want that precision engineering
you don't want like an associate's
degree engineer coming at you with a
ball trimmer you want someone who went
to mit
they spent 18 months designing the
lawnmower 3.0
18 months that's a year and a half i
can't let's say i started a book
a year and a half ago i'm not halfway
through these people revolutionized
ball shearing the lawnmower 3.0 is the
greatest body hair trimmer the world has
ever seen i'll tell you
they've got it everywhere i talked to my
friends in india and they're going ham
with the manscape 3.0 the lawnmower 3.0
they love it
they love it it's waterproof which is
great because if you're not shaving your
balls in the shower you're not living
life like a true
or i would say like an original man like
when man first walked the earth they had
to shave under waterfalls it's just
that's the only way they could get the
hair to get off their bodies so you can
live that life with this waterproof
90 minute battery and again i want to
emphasize like what i said last week
if you are shaving your balls for 90
minutes see a doctor
there is something wrong with you you
have what i
need to claim your award
yes yeah first of all give yourself a
high five because you have the hairiest
balls of all time
second of all figure out what happened
to get you to that point 90 minutes is
far too long
also i should mention there's an led
that's a light emitting diode
light so that you can see what you're
doing which is good don't try doing it
blind
for years as a challenge i shaved my
balls blind
and it was bad and i ended up having to
go to the hospital
many many times don't be like me they've
also got quiet stroke technology
in this 7000 rpm trimmer motor that's a
scary number 7000 rpms at your family
jewels it better be precision engineer
that's like a race car engine coming in
to hedge your
testicles okay get 20 off free shipping
right now with the code
rogue theory at manscape.com that's 20
off and free shipping
at manscape.com use the promo code rogue
theory now i want to give two gentle
thumbs up to shipstation if you're an
e-commerce seller right now
is a wild time people are ordering
things left and right
ship station is here to help with new
rockstars has tried to ship things in
the past
it was confusing figuring out the
logistics and the cost of everything
philip would tell me tommy you can't
keep ordering visors visors are out of
style we don't make those
so we had a lot of trouble now ship
station helps online sellers of any size
get orders out quickly
save money on shipping and keep their
customers happy which i'm told based on
all the economics classes that i took
that if you keep the customers happy
you will stay in business uh they'll get
your shipping rates normally reserved
for fortune 500 companies it's the
fastest
and easiest and most affordable way to
manage and ship your orders just a few
clicks and you'll be managing your
orders
and getting your product to happy
customers which as we said before
happy customer happy business chip
station works with all major carriers
and their interface brings your products
together
whether you're selling them on etsy
amazon or your own website
shipstation is the number one choice for
online sellers you'll ship more and less
time
with the best rates available and right
now you can try shipstation free
for 60 days when you use the offer code
rogue make sure your business is ready
to meet the demands of delivery culture
way better than cancel culture i know i
said that last week but delivery culture
those people are brutal on twitter
get started at ship station today click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in rogue do not try
and sing into it it's a fake microphone
at the top of the page
type in rogue that's shipstation.com
then enter the offer code rogue
shipstation.com
make ship happen there are more reasons
than ever why you might not be getting
great sleep right now
but your mattress shouldn't be one of
them helix sleep makes personalized
mattresses made right here in america
and ships straight to your door with
free no contact delivery that means they
don't sleep on them first which is rare
most mattress places they sleep on them
72 hours they roll around they get their
stink on them
and that's how they mark them that's how
they know how to service your mattress
you got to get your mattress changed
every 3000 miles
free returns and 100 night sleep trial
is all yours with helix sleep
choose a mattress helix made a
two-minute quiz way too long that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences i'm kidding if you can't
take a two-minute quiz
reassess your life okay they made a
two-minute quiz that matches your body
type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you speaking of perfect
body types and mattresses eric
why don't you tell us a little bit about
your helix mattress oh yeah yeah okay so
i filled out this quiz
and i uh i got this helix it's like a
queen size it's a
it's like a dusk looks or lux or
something
i feel like i'm being propped up i have
i have just the right amount of support
and it's like a nice little spring to it
so it's like
it's it doesn't make me want to roll
over it's like i'm already in the
perfect like groove
you know like your dream couch has your
ass groove already baked in there it
like knows you
this is this is what i'm experiencing
right now best sleep in my
life best sleep of your life helix
mattress
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick
in the 2020 mattress oscars just kidding
it was by gq
wired magazine and apartment therapy the
holy trinity of mattress judges guys
and by tom bechtold i also rate it great
and there's only one person that used to
review my mattress because there's only
ever been one person on it
i sleep alone eight years running just
go to helix
sleep.com rogue theory take their two
minutes sleep quiz
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
whether there's one person or ten i
don't know what you do with your spare
time
are you in a deca couple are you in a
throuple are you in an octa couple
that's great how fun for you must be
nice to have that type of human contact
they have a 10 year warranty are we even
going to live that long that's house
money baby
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
and honestly do you want to see the look
in the helix mattress delivery guy's eye
when you send a child back to him
it's just heartbreaking keep the
mattress you're going to love it
i promise you helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows i only need one
like i said so one of you might get one
as a gift
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
rogue theory that's dot helixsleep.com
slash rogue theory good night bye tommy
tommy guys
uh eric will you tell us about the
discord
oh yeah so all of you know that uh every
week we like to play rogue theory with
our friends on discord our generous
supporters there and this week
we asked them the question about this
new mutants trailer that just dropped
during comic con
where we saw these creepy ass smiley
dudes with a razor teeth no eyes
and so we just asked him like what the
hell are those things like
how are they related to the story what's
the story behind them and we had three
really really good theories but the best
one
was our friend gandalf uh dr
adam brashear also known as i had this
awesome theory he posts all kinds of
great theories on her discord uh but
this one was
was for rogue theory and it was he went
into the ways that this will connect to
the mcu
even if like they want to try to pull
that card like
he talks about how he kind of used some
of the things that i brought up in the
trailer breakdown about how i theorized
that these could be like
manifestations of magic's past drama
because it looked like they had some
russian prison tattoos on their bodies
so maybe it's like it's her demon bear
that like gets manifest and shows she
has to like conquer them
but like he found a way to like tie in
weapon x's history to this
and how like you can bring in actual
mutant history
into the mcu in like uh he ties in
everything it's like a master theory so
you gotta read this
you gotta join our discord just to read
the whole thing because he
he connected all the dots it was awesome
he has a homeland chart on his wall
he must he must thank you eric
speaking of new mutants that poor movie
already had a weird delayed history
before coronavirus screwed up movie
release schedules and it was shot in
2017 but it had been pushed back
multiple times due to reshoots and the
fox disney mergers
so many things have happened they
released new footage and did a comic con
at home panel for the film last week
and it's scheduled loosely finger quotes
to come out in theaters next month but
who knows if that's gonna happen
um so guys pitch me on
if and how new mutants will ever be
released oh i got this i
i uh to me this troubled film
is the perfect dance partner for a
troubled platform
this reeks of a quibby joint does it
i'm not i'm not kidding i'm not joking
this is the i mean this entirely
honestly
chop this movie up into five or six
parts
twelve or ten minutes long release it
weekly
thomas you have a wire tommy
why are people angry about this who is
excited for this movie
who even really knows how this movie's
gonna tie in what kind of horrible
patchwork are they gonna have to do to
make this make sense at the mcu
why not just have it come out as this
really really really expensive
star-studded quirby series and maybe get
some marvel
cynical fanboys over to quippy for a
little bit where there's actually some
decent content
that people just refuse to watch it's a
win for quibby
it's a kind of a loss but at least a
daring risk for disney to try and do a
little something with the quibs
first of all quibby should be pronounced
qui bye because it's quick bites
it's not qui beets qui beats quick beats
so i'm going to say the new mutants need
to be needs to be on quiv eye
yesterday but i've always learned that
two negatives make a positive and i
don't think this is any different guys
maybe i'm a dreamer maybe i'm just a guy
that spends 90 minutes mowing his lawn
with a manscaping 3.0
tommy that's not what it's for tommy oh
sorry i called my i call my groin my
lawn oh
okay who would do that who would use
that as a weird extended metaphor for
their product
i don't know that's yeah oh my god
i can't i i i need to go next because i
feel like i
i i can't possibly come up with a better
idea than
to release this on quibby so let me just
you can go next um i'm gonna give
tommy uh two little little rogies
because because here's why unki tommy
yes cause that was the worst idea i've
ever heard
[Laughter]
however however i'm giving you two full
rogies
because no one sells anything harder
than ankitami
oh boy that one uh tired me out that
stressed me out
and i'm not even a shareholder in quibby
that stressed me out um
i listen gang i'm gonna be real i
thought about this
and i just keep coming to the conclusion
of i feel so bad
i feel so bad for everybody involved i
feel so bad for these people that made
this movie
that was like yeah this would be part of
the x-men franchise and it was like
still a thing you know a couple years
ago i feel so bad for these actors that
have grown into adults since they made
this movie
i just i have heard this argument
online before and i feel like i side
with this side of the argument which is
people feel now so bad for new mutants
the movie that
the one camp is going do a digital
release the tommy camp is going put it
on quibby
and the one other camp is going just
let them have a theatrical release even
if it takes another 18 years like
let them let like because because if
it's about the momentum of the x-men
franchise that's gone the moment has
passed certainly so that's not going to
help
so at this point i say push it into 2021
find a cool month for like a horror
movie thing maybe next october
you know to kind of counter programming
for like halloween kills or whatever but
just let them have their movie in
theaters
let it be the last remnants of the fox
arab x-men world
you know don't put the type of pressure
on it to be like this is it gonna tie
into the mcu it's probably not
it's just like you know people are going
to be disappointed in that way i'm like
look
just push it a year put it in theaters
whenever theaters are able to safely
open whenever we have a vaccine whatever
the thing is
and that will also give me a year's time
to re-watch all the x-men movies so that
i'll be really ready
really ready to watch new mutants which
probably has nothing to do with the
x-men movies but
i just want to give them a theater man i
feel so bad
yeah that made me feel sad for them
it's just sad yeah
it's really hard to make yeah i know
yeah listen they're well paid they're
all
good-looking young actors they've got
their whole careers in front of them i
didn't see the comic con panel but
apparently people
that watch it they were like they're
very clearly over
promoting this movie and i'm like i bet
they are
i bet they are that's a real bummer that
they have to keep doing that so
yeah great great job hector um i'm
giving you two
uh two more rogies um there's a
there's a giant candle behind you which
might turn this count as two
they turned into a green sharpie and a
thick black sharpie thanks marina
thank you thoughtful and that's because
you chose the safest route right
safe for all of us like right like don't
don't force it just like let us all be
safe
and also um the kindest route
so that's why you get two ruggies um and
also
i wanted to see everybody turn these
into more things tommy you didn't turn
yours into anything so what are oh
mine actually it's so funny turned into
a copy of the
mighty miss malone by
christopher paul curtis we are a family
on a journey to a place called wonderful
is the quote on the back
uh and then it also turned into the
story of
arthur true love a story of arthur true
loved by elizabeth berg
uh jane hirschfeld says elizabeth berg
reminds us both
of both the richness of any human life
and the hearts needed resilience so
go ham jane i guess she really liked it
do you know what's funny is that one of
these i hope that this gets back to at
least one of these authors
yeah is that they're like you know
someone's like
you're on a rogue theory podcast from
new rockstars
for a book that you wrote for a book you
wrote eight years ago yeah
yeah this is an amazon review that's
like
rogue theory sent me here great the way
guys i want to point out the
the mighty miss malone retails for only
five dollars in paperback so i mean
absolutely steal good deal
eric when do you how do you think this
is going to come out or should
all right i i i hear both arguments
well i hear one of the arguments uh
sorry hector quimby quimby is actually
i see this going no no no i think we got
to just release it on disney plus
right i i feel like this should have
been there uh the
moment of launch of disney plus now the
only argument against it i see is like
or there's two arguments one if this is
like a christopher nolan style tenant
movie that needs to be seen on the big
screen
uh and two if like the actors or
producers or directors or creatives i
would say behind it
really are counting on the back end
sales of that movie
it seems like this is the kind of movie
where most of the people were paid up
front you know at least the actors maybe
josh boone had some deal with the
studios like i get
10 if so give him the full
new subscriptions for disney plus that
come in as a result of it just give him
all
seven dollars of every you know a
million person who who signs up as a
result
uh i just think this doesn't seem like a
movie that needs to necessarily be seen
on big screen you got you know uh arya
stark you got
uh charlie heaton from stranger things
both of them are like small screen stars
anyway uh and like this is just like an
opportunity to get a ton more signups
for disney plus so that when like you
know falcon winter soldier drops so that
when uh mandalorian season two drops
they're already there well it's like
there's an opportunity to build out the
app and and create more of a demand
because while disney plus seems to be
doing well
it's nowhere near the market share that
netflix has netflix has already taken
over the world
these other studios are just trying to
get a slice of that pie so like this is
a chance for like disney plus to really
grow its market share
and uh any profit that you make from it
just like make sure to give the
creatives a cut of it because like
yeah they they will be missing out uh
make sure that they're taken care of
is the only thing i really care about
there it and the other thing too is
disney plus
has kind of been quietly putting x-men
in fantastic
movies yeah yeah on there over the past
couple weeks and months it's like oh
okay yeah you guys are you guys are
reaching into that
pile of movies that you have yeah so it
would kind of be fitting to be like
you've seen x-men days of future past
you've seen fantastic four
now it's new mutants we're the marvel
channels
something that doesn't connect it all
but hey the pumps pumps are primed pumps
are primed
eric that's great um and i'm giving you
three full damn it three
go ahead three full rogies uh because
i have disney plus so i will get to see
yes yes and when i'm
judge jury that's what's that's what
counts
perfect judge jury coronado law
yeah yeah uh eric what did those turn
into uh turns into
my chewbacca um bobblehead from the last
jedi
the only star wars film uh and then
turns into the board game
pandemic that used to be my favorite
game and now i'm too afraid to play
um because it's too realistic
eric is this jumanji your fault did you
jumanji us
playing pandemic oh son of them
finish finish the game eric never
because my third thing turns into my
pixar water bottle
which was given to me by um my lovely
girlfriend kelly who works
at pixar and uh uh was here the moment
coronavirus
kicked in and everything's shut down so
it really was my wish that she could
stay with me
for the weekend that it still lasted and
uh i'm sorry but it's been worth it i i
won't wish it back
no regrets uh guys right now
uh eric and hector are actually tied
with tommy uh so close behind
so close and just a quibby length away
just a quibby length away
[Laughter]
uh but don't worry we will determine the
winner and
and it's going to be hector no matter
what
[Music]
with our round of rogue questions which
are rapid fire
so are you guys ready yeah here we go
question number one natalie portman said
in an interview
that she's gonna try to get jacked for
thor iv
what character in the mcu would you most
be surprised to see show up in crazy
good shape
i'm gonna say hank pym like
he's been so obsessed with seeing uh the
digital effects people
um reduce his age so he's like i want to
do that for real
and he just has like that jk simmons
jacked bod in the next movie
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna say
i'm gonna say groot i'm gonna say if
root showed up ripped i would be
concerned i mean i guess he could
probably
make like you know his arms into
redwoods but still
if brute has like cut abs and like
biceps i would be a little nervous i'd
be surprised that is weird
yeah i i would be surprised at one of my
favorite actors
in these movies and one of my favorite
characters dude the great supporting
role of
ned leeds played by jacob from the
spider-man movies if he showed up super
jack because he's a bigger guy he's a
bigger guy
and he is such a great ally to peter
parker kind of a civilian role
in the comic books the character he
plays is named ned leeds
and ned is a bit more fit and he ends up
kind of becoming
one of the men who was dressing up like
the hobgoblins he becomes sort of like a
but he was kind of framed and so he has
an interesting sort of sort of
more soap opera backstory with peter
parker and
and other people in their sort of social
circles i would be blown away
if people that were making the mcu were
like yeah jacob we need you to get
super jacked you're gonna be the bad guy
i'd be like what yeah he's the guy in
the chair
yeah leave me he's a guy in the chair
that's great uh
tommy i liked your answer best but i'm
gonna give a point to hector anyway
chris wow thank you all right that's all
man
i'm never gonna be invited back
everybody's gonna hate me i know it's
really because
it's probably because i'm the judge
that's right question number two
disney plus is developing a movie about
kids that turn into their halloween
costumes which is also just a goosebumps
book
that i read like it's 100 yeah disney
yeah that's a haunted mask i read that
one
yeah it's 100 yeah what the goosebumps
book is
anyway what halloween costume that you
guys wore as a kid
would you least want to turn into
oh for me uh as a as a really small kid
like a five-year-old me and my sisters
and my uh
cousins all dressed up as california
raisins
and and i could see you remember they
had a hot minute where like the
california raisins had like a christmas
special and like a tv show
so i would say for a variety of reasons
not the least of which
the uh the appearance of a grown man
with that type of like
appearance might be problematic and it
was i think we used garbage bags for the
raisins that would be very suffocating i
think you know so
uh for me the california raisins being a
lifestyle would be difficult
if you did it now you just look like a
giant testicle that's right yeah and
that's some people do say that is what i
look like so maybe
tommy tommy stop uh
when i when i was a kid my mom made me a
custom
uh made costume for one of my favorite
cartoon characters
but if i were to turn into this
character today i would hate
my life and that character was daffy
duck my mom made me a daffy duck costume
with like a custom like like bill that
came out so i had like
a like a hat that i put on and then i
had like a black costume and the sort of
like
orange like leggings and i was daphne
duck but
daffy duck i love daffy duck i would
hate to be daffy everybody hates daffy
duck he's
awful he gets shot in the face
constantly he gets [ __ ] on non-stop
i would i would want to be bugs maybe
yeah you know because he's a he's a
stinker he's the guy in control you know
he's able to mess with people
but daffy duck is perpetually not
learning the right lessons
and uh and and going through the world
people would be like what is this looney
tunes back in action
get out of here daffy duck and i'd be
like come on let me on the studio i work
at warner brothers they'd be like
we don't understand how a cartoon can be
walking around this makes no sense and
i'd probably be captured by the
government or killed because i
should not exist i would be an
abomination to nature
[Laughter]
oh my god that's a really good answer uh
eric
um i'm trying to think when i dressed up
in halloween costume my parents are a
bit older i'm like the youngest of five
so they would never like
bother to figure out what i was gonna
wear so i would just like put on like a
ski mask and be like i'm a burglar
i'm a robber and i uh but no one could
tell
it was me so i think i ran to some
neighbors who were trick-or-treating
they're like who are you and
they're my older sister katie's friends
so i said
i'm katie's sister but i meant to say
katie is my sister
so that's all i remember for halloween
but that that
saying that has given me so much social
anxiety over the years just that
confusion
and the idea i've had so many stress
streams in which i'm a criminal
which i'm a burglar or which like i'm on
i've murdered someone
so i i would not want to turn into like
a real life uh
criminal because they think that your
hands put your hands in the air i'm
katie's sister
they shoot me in the face they're like
yeah your costume is katy's sister
that's right
i'm katie's sister i'm katie's sister
it's like the santa claus where i just
grow long hair and
yeah i play volleyball yeah
that's great uh i i liked eric's answer
the best but i'm still gonna give
hector
oh man this is great i'm just
hector feels bad but he shouldn't
because i'm the villain here
the answer to question one topic one is
who's the villain it's really me
[Applause]
last one guys a guy in full dark knight
joker cosplay was seen
riding a jet ski in the east river in
new york city
in your best joker voice what would he
say
while riding that jet ski so in florida
we associate jet skis as like the number
one mortal enemy to manatees
because people on jet skis just random
they don't obey
no wake zones they don't give a [ __ ]
they'll just go run over these poor
endangered sea cows
that are beautiful and sweet and eat
lettuce um
but uh so i would imagine joe uh joker
uh taking a jet ski down the st john's
river running over a manatee and going
you want to know how you got these scars
that's great that's great joker on a jet
ski would go like this
and here we go
and then just looks like you let the jet
ski go yeah
yeah yeah yeah
mine would be uh sad boy joker from
joker movie
and he would say my mother
always told me i was the best jet skier
they would smile and they'd be like hey
man can you just get off the jet ski
with someone else
ride it and then he would shoot them
nice um i actually liked
uh eric and hector's the best
and tommy's the best but guess what
all three of these go to hector wow
[Laughter]
hector you don't have to do four more
but but what do all of these
rogies turn into uh well i'm gonna need
some help from tommy tommy can you help
me out
one of them turned into this book read
the cover
jackie chan never grow up
it's the story of jackie chan as a
little boy in london who
is sprinkled with fairy dust and travels
to a far away land of neverland where
it's
nothing but martial arts from there baby
watch as jackie chan
battles the treacherous captain jet li
in a battle between good and evil
jackie chan never grow up from random
house
this book retails at 74. and is
autographed by the author
uh guys that's it that's it for rogue
theory
uh eric you had one two three four five
rogies tommy you had four rogies uh
but hector had one two three four five
six seven eight nine
ten oh my god
rick none of you ever stood a chance
i'd like to dedicate my win to eric and
tommy that's what i'm doing right now
i'm splitting it up
you deserve it you deserve it you just
did the mean girls uh
tiara crack and we each get a piece
that's right
i'm the real villain and hector is the
hero
guys that's it for this episode of rogue
theory so
thank you to our guest anki tommy
thank you for having me tony where can
we find you on online
you can find me online in the darkest
corners of the deep web
at tommy bechtol just like my name is
spelled it's not pronounced vegetal it's
not pronounced [ __ ] told like the guy
who called my house the other day
wanted to pronounce it it's bechtel the
beck told you a story
great uh and as always thank you eric
voss
thank you thank you it's been great and
uh keep an eye on the channel this week
we got some great stuff like
uh original x-men breakdown i'm not
gonna be saying the director's name
during that video
but i'll be talking about hugh jackman
and uh charles xavier
patrick stewart plenty yeah great and
uh hector guys give it up for hector
our what a great
what a great guest what great thank you
so much where can we find you
you can follow me on the internet on
twitter and instagram at hector is funny
and uh thank you guys so much for having
me this was an absolute blast
um hector what was your wish did you do
a wish or no
whoa my wish for coronavirus to be over
for coronavirus to be over why would i
wish for anything else we've been
waiting for someone to wish for that in
an episode now we'll find out yeah
because somebody jumanji does
because somebody just really jumanji the
hell out of this
great well hector hector won but he he
asked for a wish that i cannot grant but
maybe if we all wish hard enough
wait i have an extra a separate wish
okay okay marina
i wish that marina would tell us her
favorite line from the movie blade
great uh my my favorite line from the
movie blade is
some [ __ ] are always trying to
ice skate up hill
whatever you know yeah
listen whistler hasn't been cast in the
mcu yet
it should be marina mastro get on it
yes oh what a dream oh my god after
a dream oh i would
die i would die guys thanks for
listening to rogue theory and podcast
and watching it on youtube
don't forget to subscribe to rogue
theory podcast feed and stay tuned
to the youtube channel for this and
other shows follow us on twitter at new
rockstars
and hit that subscribe button and
keep coming back we're gonna be here but
thankfully for everybody else i won't be
hosting all the time
so anyone's game it's anyone
oh okay yeah thanks guys
[Music]
you
[Music]